we had Dave Roberts on the show on
Monday and I asked the Dodgers skipper
the day before the game one in which
Justin Turner came up big in a big spot
what makes this young man so great it's
a magical ascension and I think that but
he's a magical person and he's a heck of
a baseball player and all the things
that have come his way he's earned and
no one works harder he's as blue-collar
as they get he loves being a Dodger he's
a winner and you know in big spots man
this guy didn't shy away for the big
moment and so i I've said it many times
but he's the glue to our ballclub and we
wouldn't be here without him and the
Dodger glue in Dodger blue joining us
here on the Richardson show Justin
Turner fresh off of that big home run in
game number one in the World Series how
you doing Justin I'm doing good how you
doing I'm doing fine what does it mean
to hear stuff like that from your
skipper uh yeah you know doc and I have
a great relationship and you know he
pumps me full of confidence every day
and tries to keep me going and keep me
keep me talking to the guys and making
sure everyone's on the same page pulling
the same direction and you know
obviously you know he's he's a world
champion and I'm just trying to get in
that club with him
well I guess before we get to the
present-day I'd love to talk with you
about your journey Justin because it's
so fascinating to me the number of times
many of my listeners and viewers have
also been told the word no or you can't
in their careers or in their lives I'm
sure is too numerous to mention what was
it about your journey that makes you who
you are today having been in the Orioles
and Mets organization for as long as you
did now you're a Dodger doing what
you're doing yeah I just uh you know
obviously I think as a kid you grow up
dreaming to play professional baseball
and and then for the Reds to take that
opportunity and draft me what's pretty
excited and then a couple years down the
road you get traded so you're that's a
little confusing you're not really sure
what that means like do they not want
you or is it a good thing because
another team does want you and then
you know the next year you get
designated for assignment by the Orioles
and you know not sure what's going on
there what's going to happen but luckily
and I've got an opportunity with the
Mets and they gave me a chance to stay
in the big leagues for four years and
right when I thought I was starting to
figure things out offensively you know
they decided I wasn't gonna be able to
help their team anymore and and was not
entered and became a four-engine
and didn't know what was going to happen
spend the whole offseason trying to
figure out where I was going to play if
I was going to play if any team was
going to take a chance and luckily for
me a guy named Ned Colletti went out on
a limb and offered me a contract to play
with the Dodgers and and you know now
Here I am today yeah the rest is
actually you know also postseason
history and we'll get to those numbers
if you don't mind in a second but I
guess so Ned Colletti gave you the
chance who else has helped shape you to
become the beast that you have become
Justin well yeah I mean baseball wasn't
granted me from the time I was two and a
half three years old I've had a bat in
my hand my dad coached me all the way up
until my freshman year of high school he
coached my travel ball teams throughout
high school but there's been a lot of
guys that you know have had an influence
in my life towards Horton was the head
coach of fortune when I played there and
the amount of baseball information that
he was able to pass on through me I
think makes me has made me a smarter
baseball players and then I would have
been if I hadn't had that experience and
then going through you know higher
leagues and the major leagues you meet
different people and you have different
conversations with guys and the chance
to play McMullen 2013 which led to doug
Latta who basically helped me completely
restructure my swing and and change the
way i think about hitting and helped me
get the ball in the air a little bit
warrant and a lot more so that was a
crucial part and then also when I got
here with the Dodgers our shrink coach
Brandon McDaniel actually moved his
family
from Omaha out to LA and offseason so he
can stay here and train with Kenley
Jansen and myself and you know
physically the these last three four
years is Dodger I've been in probably in
the best shape of my life and a lot of
that's accredits Brandon Justin Turner
Dodgers third baseman joining me here in
the Rich Eisen show now I'll just doing
the math you were just about to be four
years old here in Southern California
when Kirk Gibson hit that home run off
of Dennis Eckersley and here you are on
on an anniversary night same exact night
walking off against the Cubs if you had
told that kid growing up in Southern
California that you'd do something like
that what would that kid say Justin I
probably said that's gonna be awesome I
can't wait for it you know I I was glued
to the TV I watched baseball all the
time 24/7 that I love the game I'm a
student of the game I don't think I have
anything figured out but it's exciting
to go to the field and you know talk to
guys and have conversations and get
different perspectives and and just
continue to to learn about you know this
game that I love so much and you know I
don't think anyone will ever have it
completely figured out and not that's
the beauty of it you know you show up
every day and it doesn't matter what it
says on paper you got to go out there
and you got to play 27 outs and she got
to beat another team that you know wants
to win a game just as badly as you do so
yeah that little kid would have been he
would have been really pumped if he
heard that have you heard from Gibson
since then I did he text me the next
morning and then congratulating me and
said it was awesome you know I text him
back and said you know how great it was
and that I couldn't imagine doing that
in a World Series game and he said keep
keep going and you'll be your chance so
it was it was a pretty cool exchange
yeah coming from Gibby who you know like
you just said since the time I was three
you know he's known in my family has a
Dodger legend is pretty special Justin
Turner Dodgers third baseman fresh off
that home run in Game one joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show all right
now in terms of what you just said got
to turn the page
doesn't matter what you did last night
here comes Justin Verlander what
challenges do you believe he presents
this evening Justin yeah just for you
know quality pitches comes out guys he
attacks he's got a mountain presence out
there you know he he's got that kind of
that Clayton Kershaw mountain presence
where he doesn't waver he's not he's not
afraid of anything he's gonna attack you
he's gonna go at you and obviously the
stuffs good so for us it's about you
know breaking them down making sure we
get him in the trike zone and you know
hopefully running that pitch count up as
much as possible so we can get him out
of the game and getting that open well
interestingly enough the the teammate of
yours who would have the most experience
against Verlander and certainly be able
to download with the most knowledge I
think you know where I'm heading with
this is Adrian Gonzalez who's sitting on
a local TV sports show and not what the
team can you and there's so much
conversation about it so much criticism
heading in his direction and others
saying where to back off what would you
tell people who are having this
conversation about Adrian Gonzalez not
being with the team right now Justin hey
I talk to Adrian every single day and he
texts forward during after games and
we're constantly talking you know he's
been one of my best friends on this team
for for four years now and you know I I
have nothing had to say about the guy I
mean just because you know he might not
have been there for games physically
doesn't mean he's not still talking to
every one of us and and watching the
games and and going for us and getting
excited and you know I can promise you
when I hit that home run last night he
was sitting there watching wanting to
take a selfie like we always do so
that's that's one of my best friends
he's a Dodger he's a true daughter he
cares he loves this team he loves the
city and you know just I'll leave it at
that okay and then let's hit the Wayback
Machine just a little bit last night
we're sitting there thinking how hot it
was was it difficult to perform in that
heat 103 degrees for a Fall Classic your
first World Series game just
to focus like that uh I don't think it
was difficult to focus but it was hot it
was it was a hot like it's not even hot
in the summer here hot you know I was I
think the worst part was being out on
defense and and your hand is just
sweating so much in your glove keep kind
of you know takes you take your hand out
and dry it off so your gloves not
slipping off your hand when a ball gets
hit to do so but you know at the same
time they're playing in the same
temperature there's no excuses you go
out and play and we actually like when
it's hotter here in LA the ball flies a
little better okay
and I I do have to ask this question
Justin I know you're focused I know
you're locked in but when you step in
against Dallas Keuchel do you do you
notice the beard do you say that's a
pretty nice looking beard beard on beard
respect do you have that moment in the
batter's box going in early play okay
and didn't actually get a chance to face
Kyle Cole but I saw him by the batting
cage and I definitely complimented him
on his beard and how nice it was but
like I said media day the day before you
know the beards aren't throwing pitches
the beards aren't taking swings this is
about the guy underneath the peers you
know that's all just that's all just a
side conversation it's all it's just a
man behind the beard it's not the Bears
elf that said how much maintenance does
yours require Justin what was the last
time you you actually took a scissor to
that thing well I'm going to say that's
the difference between Dallas and myself
you know he keeps his extremely well
groomed and I don't think there's a hair
out of place
me on the other hand you know whatever
happens happens I just let it go and
maybe maybe a couple times a week run a
comb through it or something make sure
there's no bread crumbs in there but
other than that yeah I just let it have
a mind of its own and there's no female
in your life that's saying you got to do
something about this court my fiance
doesn't mind it so okay she she doesn't
- he is all on board with it and yeah
see
that's me be be whoever I want to be huh
that's why I love her understand
understand she loves you who for the man
behind the beard right just exactly
although I would imagine I don't know
we've just kind of met over the phone
here does she know you without a beard I
mean she would just only know you with a
beard as a bearded guy right no she
knows me with a very very lonely person
I had a very short manager I don't know
how to that neat-looking
our beard now and now there's this now
with now you have this and now there's
the caveman beard exactly and and a
great postseason so far and good luck
beyond Justin and I hope to chat with
you very soon and it's really been
enjoyable chat with you and watching you
play here in Los Angeles all right
thanks guys I appreciate you having me
on you bet anytime Justin Turner at red
turned to for more Rich Eisen show tuned
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app